so now i would like to introduce our
next speaker
it is my pleasure to welcome dr nicole
garrison
dr garrison is currently an assistant
professor of biology at west liberty
university in west virginia and a member
of the wv embry bioinformatics corps
faculty
she earned a phd at auburn university
working on the phylogenomics
transcriptomics and systematics of
spiders
her research utilizes a variety of next
generation sequencing technologies and
involves the development of custom
bioinformatic pipelines for a wide range
of biological applications from
conservation biology to evolutionary
biology and biomedical research
the primary foci of her current position
are aiding researches in the
pre-processing analysis and
interpretation of their sequencing data
as well as educating undergraduate
students in bioinformatics methods and
programming
so please join me in welcoming dr nicole
garrison
thank you
get my slide up here
okay so hi thank you for having me uh i
am as you said a junior faculty and
assistant professor of biology at west
liberty university
um
i have kind of a hybrid position so i
work
with the genomics core but i also teach
courses
so general biology courses and
specifically bioinformatics courses so
i'm really there to kind of develop this
bioinformatic expertise at this
primarily undergraduate institution
so this talk is just kind of about the
approach that i'm taking that we are
taking in west virginia to start
training our students and begin that
pipeline of bioinformatic expertise at
the undergraduate level
i think for a lot of us our exposure to
bioinformatics happens kind of late in
the game and so we're trying to shift
that timeline back a little bit earlier
and get some of these younger students
involved
in learning bioinformatics
so west liberty university if you're not
familiar with it which you know i
wouldn't really expect you to be is a
very small school
in kind of a rural setting in west
virginia
so we have
the distinction of being the first
institute of higher education in the
state we actually predate the formation
of west virginia
little fun fact
we have only about 2 500 undergraduates
so it's a very small campus not a whole
lot of students there
many of the students that come to our
university are local to the area or the
tri-state area
a lot of them are non-traditional
students they're returning to education
after being away
and many of them are dependent on
scholarship support
so it is kind of
an economically depressed area in some
senses a lot of our students may be
first-time or first-generation college
students as well
despite all of this we have developed a
really strong biology department at west
liberty we have a ton of undergraduate
research currently happening
and so we have students in the lab
generating data and with the advances in
sequencing we're generating more and
more big data sets
so there's this need this increasing
demand for bioinformatic expertise at
our university
we also have a developing postgraduate
program so we have mams programs and we
also have a professional positions
assistant program so there's a lot of
biomedical
biomedically oriented students that are
attending the university at different
levels
we are part of the west virginia embry
network
so we're a partner institution we work
really closely with particularly
marshall university uh especially the
genomics corps and dr jim denver
and west virginia university
we're the site of a major research
project among many other research
activities that are happening there dr
horizempa has a very well developed lab
that is looking at erythrocyte invasion
by francis ella tularensis
lots of microbiology fun sequencing
happening at west liberty
we do a lot of our sequencing most of
our sequencing at the genomics core
facility which is located at marshall
and so this is kind of the
other half of my duties is to be the
connection between the genomics core and
the west liberty faculty so when they
generate data when their students
generate data i'm there to kind of act
as the go between and help them analyze
and interpret what they have
so there are multiple sequencing
projects ongoing
many of them having to do with
francisella
but we are developing more and more
independent kind of research programs
that are utilizing this genomics core
facility
so like i said i am in this hybrid
bioinformatics support position
so
following along with these inbree goals
which i'm sure you've already heard
multiple times
we have similar goals in west virginia
we need to build expertise and capacity
for biomedical research
we want to develop those biomedical
research programs and increase
competitiveness for external funding
we want to generate student research
opportunities we already do a really
good job of that like i said
but particularly research opportunities
in bioinformatics is kind of where we're
heading in the
future and so we're trying to train this
future workforce that is equipped with
the tools to
do bioinformatic work or at the very
least communicate with
bioinformaticians that they may
collaborate with in the
future
so um i feel like bioinformatics is the
missing link right now at west liberty
and probably at a lot of institutions
across the country
researchers have very interesting
questions they generate a lot of data
because it's much cheaper to do that in
a lot of senses these days
but they face these bottlenecks and data
analysis that are really common they
also have difficulty interpreting
results that they get if they have
someone help them analyze it
they may not be able to fully interpret
what they what they are presented with
so there's just a lack of bioinformatic
expertise at the faculty level graduate
level and that all comes from this lack
of training at the undergraduate level
so that's what we're trying to correct
here
we have some really common challenges
that i'm sure you're all aware of
but there is just this lack of awareness
amongst the students the undergraduates
of bioinformatics if you ask
any given undergraduate at our
institution you know how would you
define bioinformatics they would
probably give you a blank stare
they don't have a great understanding of
what it is um or why it might be
important or useful to them
in their education um so we're really
struggling just initially with them
understanding that you know this is a
thing and it could be a useful thing for
them in their future research
there is a lot of training and resources
available free online
but i think that's part of the problem
that they face is that they don't know
where to begin
so really guided training
with one-on-one interaction is really
important at this level i believe
and it's very hard for them to come by
they may find the training materials
that they that they find on their own
and access
on their own a little unapproachable so
they're not really sure how to get
started
they don't really have the exposure to
bioinformatic careers as an option
so a lot of them come in they think that
they're you know they're going to be
pre-med they're going to be pre-vet
pre-professional programs
or they're going to you know work in a
zoo we have a huge zoo science program
but they don't really have this concept
of bioinformatics as a career that they
could attain
and they also are deterred in a lot of
cases because they're biology students
it seems like they have an aversion to
anything really heavy in computer
science or statistics or they perceive
bioinformatics to be really heavy in
both of those fields
what they don't necessarily realize is
that there are many different ways to
come at bioinformatics you can be a
biologist who picks up some computer
skills
so you don't have to be a computer
genius to begin this journey
so some potential solutions that i've
been exploring at west liberty just
first of all demystifying bioinformatics
so present those career options that are
out there in this field
and do it as early as possible and as
often as possible so kind of working
this into conversations working this
into lesson plans in more general bio
courses i think will be very helpful for
us
people who are bioinformatic ambassadors
i consider myself to be one of these
are very important so having someone on
campus who has the expertise and some
experience and can talk to you about how
they found their way to bioinformatics
and what that actually means on a
day-to-day basis
in terms of the work that they do
and again just emphasizing that there
are many different uh ways into this
this field
we also need to emphasize the role that
bioinformatics is playing in research
findings so you know again this emerging
increase in big data in all fields of
research is really important to
emphasize
that bioinformatics is going to play a
key role into the future
for analyzing that data and
understanding biological questions
and then i'm i'm going to try to empower
and engage these students so that means
providing training opportunities those
guided training opportunities
at every level really um in this talk
i'm really focusing on the
undergraduates but i think this probably
should start even at lower levels i'll
talk briefly about some k through 12
outreach that we're doing
and so to develop this um this is a
really nice simple figure
that i pulled from a recent paper so you
need to identify your training needs
which is what we're working on doing
curate materials again we're kind of in
this beginning stages of developing our
our content for these bioinformatic
training opportunities
um and
all of these things go together into
what we teach the undergraduates we
collect feedback from them
and ideally we would publish these
findings so we're not quite to the
publish openly phase of this process at
west liberty but we're hoping to get
there
someday soon
we also because we have this foundation
in undergraduate research are able to
incorporate more bioinformatic analysis
into the students research so they have
generated their data
now they can sit down and analyze it
rather than just handing it off to
someone
and then getting back the the finished
figures
so we're trying to work on getting them
to
figure out how to actually analyze their
data a little bit with us
and just in general emphasize that this
is problem solving you don't have to
have
all this code memorized that's not
really how bioinformatics happens but
you need to know where to find the tools
and how to use them and be able to
think your way through these problems
that come up
so like i said i've done some k-12
recruitment of course with covid it's
been kind of limited so this is very
recent development
actually last weekend i did a small
recruitment event where i used these
ozobots
which you can these are little
programmable robots that follow color
codes
so you can teach young kids how to
program in a really
intuitive sort of way so i had grades
three through five
young girls working on programming their
ozobots to
solve a problem or find its way through
a maze
and then
for the older kids i have actually gone
into the high school classrooms and i've
talked about next generation sequencing
introduced the concept of bioinformatics
and then we've done some really basic
mapping and variant calling on a very
small scale so just to kind of get their
feet wet get them thinking about when
they go to college you know this could
be an option for them
kind of
adding on to that coming from that
we want them to have an option once they
get to college so we are developing a
bioinformatics major at our institution
um i am developing it so right now it's
just me um and i am i'm teaching a few
different courses that are going to
ultimately be part of this major so the
first one is biological programming
which sounds a little scary got to work
on that name i think a little bit
to make it more palatable to biology
students but this is just really basic
computing skills so you get introduced
to linux the command line
a lot of you know text based
bioinformatic file processing so lots of
fast queue fasta
file processing
just learning how to automate tasks
learning the basics of programming that
they probably haven't been exposed to at
all before so
it's a class for complete beginners and
it's kind of amazing how much progress
they can make in just a single semester
i will also ultimately be teaching what
we're going to call bioinformatics one
and two um right now i'm teaching
bioinformatics one and we are doing that
um
through uh the galaxy interface so this
is a completely online
server-based
interactive
bioinformatic analysis workflows
and i find that this is really
approachable for biology students who
want to use bioinformatic pipelines for
their research
but they are not so sure that they want
to go down the route of linux and
command line and super computing they
they just really have these small
projects that they're working on they
want to know
how do i run an rna-seq pipeline really
quickly without installing anything on
my computer or finding access to some
kind of
remote server so it's pretty accessible
and we've been doing some different
tutorials with them
to kind of go through some really basic
bioinformatic methods
and then we have a ton of affiliated
courses or what i'm terming affiliated
courses so things like phylogenetic
theory which i teach in the fall
applied microbiology where the students
actually get to sequence
microbiomes and then they will analyze
it with my help
genetics courses we're working more
bioinformatics more computing into the
basic core genetics that we teach at
west liberty
and then we have the opportunity for
these independent student research
projects as well
we're also
elsewhere on campus they are developing
a data science program um that's through
the the math department so i expect
there will be a lot of overlap between
those two majors
so
we're going to enhance research
experiences by allowing them to actually
generate their own next generation
sequencing data we have an oxford
nanopore minion and we have just secured
an iseq so we will have alumina short
read and long read data for them to
analyze
so it's a really exciting time for the
bio department
they're going to have
so much data and they're definitely
going to need to know how to analyze
this for their class projects
um so that includes everything from
amplicon sequencing
some people interested in doing edna
we've had a tick microbiome
project done i've used it for
conservation genomics so looking at
relatedness of
organisms of conservation concern
and then of course we can do
rna-seq as well
we also offer summer training
opportunities um we have the shore
program summer undergraduate research
experience
that's an ongoing program at west
liberty and i'm hoping to join in more
with that in the future and actually
training one-on-one students over the
summer to to do bioinformatic research
and then really specific to
bioinformatics we offer the
bioinformatics boot camp every summer
i say every summer last year was our
first year offering it and this year
will be our second
but this is a three-week event um
it requires no previous experience we go
from
having no computational experience to
doing basic bioinformatic pipelines by
the end of this project
so
we start with an introduction to linux
and the command line
then we go in the next couple of weeks
into specific pipelines so we give them
a script that has the pipeline and then
we break this pipeline down into
digestible chunks for them so that by
the end of the week they have run the
entire thing and they can reproduce
those results if they wanted to
so we do this for a coven 19 variant
analysis and a mouse rna-seq analysis
and the data that we use is actually
from
the genomics core it's been generated by
inbree researchers in west virginia
here's kind of an example of um how the
lecture might go we do a little
powerpoint introduction typically
and at the end of it we may have some
step-by-step directions for them to
follow and explore and learn things
about the the input files and the
analyses that they're going to run
so it's
very one-on-one very guided
research they work in pairs typically
that just kind of happened naturally in
this first boot camp people sitting next
to each other kind of helping each other
out and then
jim and i would kind of circle around
and and come in when we needed to
to help them troubleshoot and get
through whatever problems they are
having
so i think this is the most important
aspect rather than the content of what
we're teaching that's pretty commonplace
and i think pretty standardized in a lot
of ways
but uh
i think the interaction that we're
having the one-on-one the guided
help that they're getting is really
important to these students
so here's an example of um
a path that we
might follow
a pipeline that we might provide them so
this is our
variant analysis on the sars coven 19
data
so
we would show them this at the beginning
and they kind of lose their minds
because it looks like gibberish and then
we walk through step by step you know
what is each of each of these commands
doing
what does this mean what happens if you
modify it in this way or that way
and then they get to see
from start to finish how this pipeline
will get executed
so we go from the raw data all the way
through to calling variants and then
looking at them
comparing them across
different samples assigned to different
students and they can compare their
variants to one another
so this is currently just open to west
virginia embry undergraduates
so that's anybody enrolled currently in
a west virginia network institution
um so it is kind of limited in terms of
who can participate at this point um and
we are capping it at about 10 students
for now
this is still kind of in the pilot phase
i would say um we're still developing
the content and the kind of core
material uh for this boot camp but we
plan on continuing doing this for
several years to come
the students at the end of this get to
do a poster presentation on um you know
an insilico manipulation of one of the
pipelines
they get to kind of test out manipulate
some of the steps use a different
program see what the output looks like
change the parameters of a particular
program
and see how that affects their
downstream results and so that's what
they present together
at this
poster
presentation at the west virginia summer
symposium
so that will happen this year as well
it'll be at west virginia university
this year
so we have a lot of potential i think to
expand participation participation in
this event
again once we kind of have our core
material down our method figured out
we will hopefully be able to share
and publish some of these curricular
modules
so we are planning on doing this but
again this is just kind of the initial
phases a really exciting time to be a
part of the development of this
bioinformatic expertise
so
if anyone is on here that is a member of
west virginia inbury
tell all of your students have them
apply
they can find us online
you can email me about it directly if
you'd like
it's a pretty good deal they get a
stipend they get housing and food paid
for
and they get to learn all of these
bioinformatic topics
and with that i think i will take
any questions that anyone has
great thank you very much nicole that
was an amazing presentation
we have questions for you okay great the
first one
yeah the first one is what is special
about people who return back to
education later in life
in terms of their ability to learn
bioinformatics and especially what
career options they end up choosing
so i'm not sure about the career options
part of that but i will say that the
non-traditional students that i've
worked with to date
and again it's a small sample size it's
a small school but they tend to be much
more focused they have a much greater
appreciation
of
you know what bioinformatics is good for
what it could be used for kind of more
perspective i guess is what they come
back with
so they are more open to kind of
exploring these methods and there seem
to be more interested than a lot of the
really young students
that come you know straight from high
school
in the career opportunities especially
so you know when i say that you can work
you know for a hospital you could work
for a private company you work for
the federal fish and wildlife service
there are all kinds of different
positions opening up for people with
these types of skill sets
so i think they see the value in that
yes definitely
so along similar lines to that um what
is the minimal set of skills
a biology oriented student must have
to kind of begin their journey into
bioinformatics
so i would say that
i kind of hesitate to frame it as the
minimal number of skills just because i
think that people with no experience are
more than capable
of picking up these skills very quickly
and i've seen it happen
i think what's more important is not
having um the fear that's associated
with kind of the stigma of oh i'm not
good at computers or i'm not good at
math um and they think that they need to
be
um like i said like rockstar geniuses
when it comes to all of these different
fields when really what's most important
is they love biology and they're willing
to
learn and try um to learn the computer
part of it
and so students who really don't like to
fail
seem to have a lot of trouble with
bioinformatics because it's
mostly failure um you know you try
something doesn't work you troubleshoot
and you figure out the problem so it is
a it's definitely a skill and a muscle
that not all of them have developed
but i think it's definitely worthwhile
even for students who don't want to
pursue a career in bioinformatics just
for the problem-solving skills alone i
think it's very valuable
yes definitely
another question does such a small
undergraduate population have benefits
when it comes to bioinformatics research
i think it does and it's kind of the
same
same set of benefits that really
are in our favor when it comes to
research we get that one-on-one approach
when the students have a question
they just walk right into my office and
talk to me about it
so they have a lot of access to
expertise
that i think you might not experience at
a larger school where you're kind of
just one of many
students in a course
and you know when i teach a
bioinformatics course i have less than
10 people typically especially at these
early stages of developing the
coursework
so i get to work with them directly and
really adapt my teaching style
and the content of the course to them
and their interests
definitely
so another question which of the
programs that you've mentioned
seemed to the greatest learning impact
on young students
of the different courses
yes i think that's what was okay
um
i think the the
the biological programming
um has the potential to have a big
impact
uh because it teaches these basic
programming skills i think it's like a
foot in the door into computer science
that they may not have experienced
before
so they know pretty quickly i think
whether or not
they like it
and then that's kind of like their first
taste that brings them
further along this career path toward
becoming a bioinformatician
great thank you and then one final
question have you had any of the your
boot camp projects results in
application
not yet
um but that would be fantastic if we
could get there one day it's such a kind
of
short program in the grand scheme of
things
we do have like the sure program is like
a nine week program and we have had
student publications result from that
so i think
it might need a little bit more time to
develop than just the three weeks but if
we had a student that was interested
they could always pick up with student
research at their institution
um or collaborate with west liberty
um into the future so
there's the potential there but it
hasn't happened yet
definitely thank you
okay
i think that is all thank you again very
much for coming and speaking with us
today dr garrison thank you